let's go to our terrific sideline
reporter Jared Greenberg all right Kevin
speaking of Vegas Giannis you are headed
to Las Vegas to spend your 29th birthday
how does that sound SS
good is it are you excited at all or
just a couple of words there yeah you
know I'm away from my family you know I
got to I got to St like team we got to
go there we have two games ahead of us I
think we're facing Indiana and after
that we're going to face another team so
I'm just trying to stay like in in the
basketball games we're going to play he
you know uh I feel I feel Joy when I'm
around my family so my family is not
going to be there so it's going to be a
weird birthday could make it a little
better you said you're going to play
roulette you're going to get at least
$100,000 so that'll make it easier are
we getting money now we got some money
that's a that's a surprise to you the
rich get
Richard hey you guys torched the NBA's
third best defense tonight Rich what
went what went into that type of
performance I think uh we played hard uh
obviously from the the start uh it was
kind of shaky uh our offense did not
have no flow to it I think coming to the
second half we moving the ball better we
were setting screens more uh we were
giving um attacking the passing the gaps
that we had we were passing the ball to
the open man uh we missed few shots so
we were able to get the lead and uh we
scored I think 145 points it it was a
team effort so I'm happy hopefully we
can keep it up do you sense that things
are starting to come together now with
this offense with you and Dame and
everyone
yeah I think uh game by game we are
getting more comfortable uh it's game
21 we have uh a lot of game uh ahead of
us I think uh as we play more minutes
together we're going to get even more
comfortable together uh we got to we got
to we got to stick it we got to we got
we got to stick together through the ups
and downs sometimes we going to play
well sometimes we going to play bad but
at the end of the day I think me and him
we setting the toe for the whole team
and uh we're on the on the same page we
we're going to sacrifice we're going to
do whatever it takes to win the game uh
some days going to be our night some
days not going to be our night but at
the end of the day we are playing to win
which is it's a good feeling right grant
hill just whispered in my ear uh Mr Hill
would like you to place some money on
black for him while you're in Vegas on
black I I only bet 34 red 34 red no
black thank you got us good luck at
Vegas guys's not playing roulette he's
the fifth leading scorer in the
NBA